-Welcome back to the show!
-Thanks for having me again.
-I love having you on the show.
I love having you.
I want to talk about
your projects.
I also think it's funny,
every time you come on with the
"Queer Eye" group, the cast,
it's so fun, because everyone
thinks that you guys
just kind of live together.
-It's like seven
or eight seasons in,
and people still think that
we live in this loft together.
-Yes.
-It really boggles my mind.
-No, it's real. It's real.
People go, like,
"Oh, that's normal. Yeah."
-It's a little concerning,
frankly. I don't know.
But like, we were even at --
we were flying from,
actually, to the Emmys
from New Orleans,
when we were filming
our latest season.
And someone stopped us
in the airport.
And this thing that they do,
they're like,
"Are you guys actually doing
an episode right now?"
And they look around to see if
there are, like, actual cameras.
And it's like --
like, we're in an airport.
Like, we're all
wearing sweatpants.
-Yeah, no, they're like,
"Oh, wait,
are you surprising me?"
-Yeah, exactly.
-"With a makeover?
Let's go!"
-It's so bizarre.
-By the way, you probably
came back from the Emmys
with an Emmy, 'cause you won
another Emmy since I saw you.
Congratulations.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to talk Halloween,
because you and your partner,
Kevin,
have some awesome
Halloween costumes.
And here's one from
one year ago. You go all-out.
This one, you were Blockbuster
back from the dead.
-Okay, so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I have to fully give credit --
He's sitting somewhere here.
-Kevin?
-Fully credit to Kev.
Kev is beyond --
he has a deep, pathological
obsession with Halloween.
October 1st, I start getting
texts during his work breaks.
Not while he's working.
[ Laughter ]
Where he starts --
-Busted.
-He starts like trying to,
like, figure out
what we're gonna wear.
We have a few that we're kind of
like, short-listing.
And then we have --
So, one of them, we were
both obsessed as kids
with "Calvin and Hobbes."
-Oh, yeah, of course.
-And he's 6'3", so he can be
Hobbes, and I can be Calvin.
-Okay.
-So that was one.
-I like that.
-Another one was
the tethers from "Us."
Jordan Peele.
-Yes. What would --
-Creepy and kind of like scary,
with the faces and everything.
-Yeah, okay, good.
-Another one was Bert and Ernie.
But I feel like
that's kind of been done.
Like, are they roommates?
[ Applause ]
-And...
-"Are they roommates?"
-There's one that I
think we're gonna go for,
but can I whisper it
in your ear?
Because we don't want to share
it with everybody,
because we want it to be,
like, a surprise.
-Quest, can you just play --
give us some music here?
[ Music playing ]
-Okay.
♪♪
-Yeah, that's good, yeah.
-Is that it?
-Yeah, that's it, but you --
-Kev, we have a winner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are we gonna get
a lot of hate?
-Yes. You'll be in a lot of
trouble, but it's very funny.
Yeah, yeah, good.
I was doing
a little research on you.
I found out that you were in a
band called the Silver Spoons.
When was this?
And talk to me about it.
-Okay.
-And I wish I had --
Your face is getting red right
now just thinking about it.
-So, the band lasted maybe about
one semester in college.
And we were so horrible.
Like, we were basically --
we were obsessed with
the Strokes and Jet
and Block Party and
Black Rebel Motorcycle Club.
-Oh, yeah.
-And Richard Ashcroft and Oasis.
So we, like, --
we wanted to just be them.
We had the long, greasy hair
that we never washed.
-Yes.
-The ripped jeans
and the cowboy boots.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
-And "Silver Spoons"?
-Silver Spoons.
-Because we were born with,
like, silver spoon.
It's so cringe!
[ Applause ]
We never played a single show.
-I go, "Do you have
any lyrics or anything?"
And you found some lyrics.
-Okay.
-Is this gonna --
-So, I literally went --
I have this journal
that my sister got me
that I've literally had since --
since before May 20th, 2004.
Where I would just write about
my existential angst
and trying to
figure out my life.
And I wrote a song
that I thought was
so clever at the time.
And it's called "Jackie."
-Ooh.
-And it was like,
"Am I writing about a girl
or a bottle of Jack Daniels?"
I even drew a bottle of Jack
on the side.
Like it's so -- it's so cringe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Jackie."
Can I just hear a couple lyrics?
-Yeah.
"Hey, Jackie, I see you up
behind the bar.
Don't hide, 'cause I can see
exactly where you are."
Like, that sounds predatory.
[ Laughter ]
"Come to me, don't run, 'cause
you won't get very far."
Okay, that's --
[ Laughter ]
That didn't age well.
-Yeah, it's about Jack Daniels,
but it could be about Jackie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for doing that.
-This is my gift to you.
-Thank you for doing that.
I will never show anyone
the full lyrics.
But this is awesome,
that you trust me this much.
Let's talk about your new hit
show, "Easy-Bake Battle."
-Yes.
-It's loosely based --
-Things that I'm
not embarrassed about.
--- on the Easy-Bake Oven.
-Yes.
-I think it's brilliant.
And the show features a lot of
hacks, which I'm into.
As someone who cooks,
do you know a lot of hacks
that you want to share
with the world or...?
-I feel like there are so many
hacks that I use that,
you know,
chefs use traditionally
that I notice that
home cooks are using now
on TikTok,
that are coming up.
Like, we had peeling ginger with
a spoon to remove the skin
instead of cutting it off,
so you, like,
lose too much of the flesh.
-I didn't know that.
-You can
microwave a potato and make
amazing mashed potatoes,
which I had no idea about.
-Really?
I don't know about that either.
-Right?
-No.
-If you burn yourself --
My father taught me this,
He's a physician.
I think it's a fact.
Let's just go with it.
Dads -- When are dads wrong?
If you burn yourself,
the coldest part of your body
is actually your ear lobe,
because there's
the least amount of circulation.
So, you can cool yourself off.
Because you often burn yourself,
if you touch something
with your index finger.
So, you can cool yourself off
with your ear lobe.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-This is what I'm talking about.
This is the hacks we want.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
This is "Easy-Bake Battle."
Take a look.
-All you need is sushi rice,
a little bowl of water,
a selection of
literally whatever you want,
ice cube tray with Saran wrap.
You get it already.
-I'm done.
I never thought of this.
-And a little scoop as well.
Just put in whatever elements
you want into the bottom.
So, then, this scoop gives you
the perfect amount of rice.
And then what I do
is just wet my fingers,
because you don't want those
little grains to stick.
And then just press it in.
And the best thing about this,
it's literally ready.
♪♪
-Cute.
Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
Instant sushi? Come on!
-Isn't that cute?
-Yes, I love that.
-Yeah!
-Antoni Porowski.
"Easy-Bake Battle" is streaming
on Netflix right now!